[Music]
in your cover story and in your book you
talk about a war on the west what kind
of shape is that war taking
in my view what's happening is a
vicious unrelenting remorseless attack
on everything that constitutes the west
as we know it
the west's history the peoples of the
west the culture of the west all the
institutions of the west the traditions
of the west
and this is this has been growing for
quite a long time now you could argue
it's been growing for the best part of
at least half a century and then it has
sped up massively in the last few years
and as i say in my cover story in the
spectator this week
one of the most visible things is this
war on the history of the west the war
on the history of a country like britain
so that you know every single one of our
institutions from
kew gardens to
um
the national trust
to the tate to the british library to um
the globe theater all seem to be all the
things that are meant to be effectively
custodians of our history have actually
started to wage a war on that history so
that they present our history as if
there's just nothing good about it and
as i say in my cover piece one of the
many devastating things about this is
that a country and a culture and a
society can only be held together if
first of all it has some agreement on
its past and secondly
it thinks that past is broadly good
because if you don't think you were good
in the past why would you do anything in
the present right but is this so much
different to what we had during the cold
war for example i mean and america was
hugely divided to come i remember seeing
some figures recently about how many
domestic bombings there were in america
in a typical year in the 1960s in
britain you had full-on communist
parties in america youth communist
parties in britain who were making um
absolutely devastating critiques uh well
not very effective but they were you
know very much at war with capitalism
with the basics of today
is it really
but now we've just got a few students
pulling down statues i mean is it really
worse
well it started with students and as
andrew sullivan famously said it's built
out and now we all live on campus
it's now gone through every corporation
every government department it isn't
just a few students anymore there was a
time when you could argue that it was
but the students left university and
they and they went right out into the
marketplace and they had jobs to go to
you know one of the jokes on
conservatives in recent years was that
conservatives often joked in the last
generation these people doing these
ridiculous degrees they're gonna go out
into the real world they'll discover
there aren't any jobs for them the
market will assert itself flat out wrong
the joke was on us there were plenty of
jobs for these people to go on into they
went into hr departments they they went
into the civil service they were the
ones who passed the civil services
demand that for any public appointment
any civil service appointment you have
to demonstrate a belief in and and
devotion to diversity inclusion equity
all things which are in their
fundamentals as i say in the piece
western you cannot dedicate yourself to
this new pseudo-ideological pseudo
religion because in part everything
about it is against the institutions and
the history of what the country used to
believe in until yesterday so you know
the big difference between now and the
cold war was first of all in the cold
war there was some unity because there
was some recognition of a shared foe but
secondly there were still adults there
were still adults in the room willing to
stand up for traditions willing to stand
up for history willing to say that
actually we have virtues as a country
and not just vices virtues as a people
not just vices things that we did well
in our history not just things we did
ill and today look around the public
square
all of the adults fled the scene
every corporation in britain every
government department every publishing
house everybody sees the same thing the
people you describe as the sort of
highly ideological students make all of
the running the shouting the desecration
of the past and the adults give in
effectively what we are living through
now in britain and then the wider west
is a cultural revolution and it's a
cultural revolution where the adults
have been intimidated into either
silence or going along with it
but douglas you say there was a common
enemy in the cold war but we're getting
one now aren't we since putin's invasion
of ukraine there has been a strikingly
coherent and as far as i can work out
spontaneous response from europe and
america and beyond into presenting a
united front against him
well
it's a very important point you just
made
the russian invasion of ukraine seems to
some extent to have have fortified
certain people it seems to have
clarified the minds of some people it's
answered the 30 year old question that
we all asked of wither nato what's the
point of nato that question isn't being
asked anymore when sweden and other
countries join nato later this year that
will be a very interesting answer in
itself but
here is the problem it's not just
putin's russia in the 21st century that
poses a threat a far bigger threat a far
bigger challenge in the 21st century is
china the communist party of china which
as i mentioned in the book is the only
country in the world putin's russia is a
basket case it was even before this war
especially is after it the only country
in the 21st century likely to catch up
with and then supersede america and the
western nations as the global power the
most important economy in the world is
china led by the chinese communist party
and that pumps out anti-western
propaganda all the time just this past
week the china daily news one of the
organs of the chinese communist party um
pumped out a vision of uncle sam behind
the oval office desk and a pile of
corpses and said that america is all
about racism and and so on there's two
points to make here the first is of
course this is totally cynical i mean
ask any of the muslims in xinjiang
whether the chinese communist party
actually minds about family separations
or racism and you'd get an answer but
secondly the problem that exists now is
not chinese anti-westernism or russian
anti-westernism or or middle eastern
anti-westernism it is western
anti-westernism it is white people doing
this against white people it is white
people
deciding that our history is all a
history of racism and that we're racist
now and institutionally racist now and
somehow derek chovin who was convicted
of the killing of george floyd is the
emblematic figure of the west and this
isn't a fringe thing you know no less a
figure than the u.s
ambassador to the un went to the u.n
last year and condemned her own country
for institutional racism something which
by the way the chinese communist parties
envoy to the un found incredibly useful
when he stood up to make his remarks and
said this is the first time that the
country has come to the united nations
and confessed its guilt
so the problem is not the external
challenge the problem is the internal
one the problem is people in the west
have been taught to think horribly about
the west so that our history is only a
history of repression and slavery and
colonialism our history is uniquely bad
not uniquely good here's here's the most
important point in a way and it's
something i bring across not just in the
book but in in my peaceful spectator
this week we have evidence for the fact
that this is flat out wrong how do we
know because the football proves it the
un published another study just in the
last year asking people around the world
fleeing not just conflict but economic
deprivation where do you want to go what
are your destinations people do not flee
to putin's russia they do not flee to
venezuela they do not flee to communist
china the number one destination that
people around the world want to go to is
the united states of america and britain
and canada and others follow shortly
afterwards now that says something it
says that whilst our society is being
told we have nothing to be proud of the
world wants to come here that whilst we
are being told we live in a racist
society and a bewildering array of
people want to come here and here's the
important thing about that it's not just
in the present
our present is not as it is by accident
it's come about because of our past if
there's something good in our present
it's because we must have done something
good in the past and that's what i want
people to realize and to be able to
focus on if we had to unite as a country
as a civilization as a culture we need
to recognize not just that we've done
some things well but we've be done more
things well than anybody else and it's
proved in the footfall of the people who
want to come here and one final thing
douglas isn't another thing we do well
arguing with each other i mean you talk
about these divisions and this huge
cantankerousness but isn't that the sign
of a west succeeding i mean there isn't
much war institutions in north korea
right now there's not much in the way of
public debate wouldn't you expect a
successful thriving west to be
absolutely at loggerheads over culture
music history the whole gamut
absolutely and as i say in the book i
absolutely encourage that i want to shut
down no debate but currently we have had
an entirely one-sided debate in recent
years there was a time when the debate
was one-sided in the opposite direction
few generations ago if you were taught
about colonialism in british schools you
were taught only the good things um a
few generations ago if you studied
american history you might not have
known that thomas jefferson owned slaves
today it's the only thing people know
about the founding fathers in america so
here's the thing i want there to be a
rigorous debate i want there to be a
thriving debate but i do not want it to
be one-sided and the people who have
been attacking white people in recent
years and being saying racist things
about white people have been a one-sided
monotone discussion and they've got away
with it for too long the people who've
attacked our culture and all of our
heroes from winston churchill to lord
nelson these people have been doing a
one-sided attack on our history i
believe that the british public and the
wider western public have the right to
have a more honest appraisal of
ourselves and our past and that includes
the right
to have pride in our past because as it
happens it's not just vital for a
society to hold together but the facts
just happen to be on our side
douglas thank you for your appraisal and
for your cover story in this week's
magazine
[Music]
you